on vaevenenir sur ce drame qui a eu lieu
mardi à
elette
elette à côté de rou un employé d'une
armerie a tué TR un des trois hommes qui
tentait de le braquer il a été placé en
garde à vue mais aujourd'hui on a appris
que le braqueur qui a été tué par
l'armurier était lui-même recherché pour
le meurtre d'un ad alors est-ce que la
place de cet armurier est en prison
a-t-il eu raison de se défendre en
ouvrant le feu on en parle dans un
instant voilà sa place est-elle en
prison oui non vous connaissez mon avis
je pense il est différent de celui de
Gilles verdè c'est sûr et certains petit
recap et on en parle juste après cette
tentative de vol à main armée a eu lieu
en plein jour dans l'armurie desl petit
village calme de scène maritime vers
11h30 trois personnes armées entrent
dans cette boutique pour la braquer le
commerçant attrape une arme dans des
circonstances qui restent à éclaircir
des coups de feu sont échangés et l'un
des braqueurs est mortellement blessé
ces de complices prennent la fuite l'un
d'eux sera arrêté un peu plus tard par
les gendarmes l'armurier lui aussi sera
placé en garde à vue pour s'expliquer
sur les conditions dans lesquelles le
malfaiteur a été tué et notamment savoir
si le commerçant était ou non en état de
légitime défense question alors tout le
monde dit non à part G autour de la
table he non Jean-Michel tu dis non bah
non je sais pas quand pour moi c'est un
principe de base quoi quand on veut pas
se retrouver face à une arme on braque
pas on braque pas une banque on braque
pas une armurerie on fait pas de choses
comme ça comme voilà comme si on veut
pas se faire arrêter par les flics on
met sa ceinture on fait pas d'excè
vitesse et cetera quand on récolte quand
on sème quelque chose récolte voilà là
c'est dommageable évidemment que
quelqu'un meurt mais Pau vieux il s'est
défendu il s'est défendu il voit
quelqu'un arnaquer il sait pas s'il soit
armé au moment o on tire on sait pas si
la personne en face est armée on se dit
que c'est sa vie ou la mienne et cetera
on se défend moi je pense que je feris
exactement la même chose si la vie de ma
famille est en danger et que j'étais
armé que je voyais trois personnes qui
arrivent qu'à gouler et ben franchement
je ferais tout pour protéger ma famille
vous avez une armuie pu il est dans une
armuie Guillaum ce qui est terrible dans
ces affaires c'est qu'on peut être
totalement innocent et basculer devenir
un criminel du jour au lendemain et moi
je mets à la place du mec qui bosse dans
une armurie qui travaille qui se lève le
matin qui se retrouve victime victime
d'un braquage un braquage c'est terrible
c'est traumatisant c'est extrêmement
violent et qui tue malgré lui qui tue
pour se défendre alors évidemment
peut-être qu'il aurait pu se défendre
autrement mais qui a commis la première
erreur c'est le braqueur et je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui se poser la question de
l'envoyer en prison et sil doit aller en
prison c'est terrible pour lui parce
qu'encore une fois s'il n'y avait pas eu
ce braquage ça ne serait jamais arrivé
c'est sans doute quelqu'un d'honnête
enfin le dossier doit le montrer ou pas
mais qui se lève le matin qui qui qui
qui va travailler et et se retrouver
coupable et criminel à cause de
quelqu'un qui a voulu commettre du mal
qui a voulu braquer moi je suis désolé
mais j'ai aucune peine aucune pitié pour
les braqueurs pour les mecs qui qui sont
violents qui veulent braquer les gens
qui veulent terroriser les gens et les
voler c'est c'est regrettable qu'il soit
mort mais je ne souhaite pas que cet
homme aille en prison l'employé Gil
Verdez c'est regrettable qu'il soit mort
la mort c'est dramatique c'est pas
regrettable la mort de quelqu'un est
toujours dramatique moi j'ai répondu oui
j'ai lui bah non mais j'ai répondu ou la
mort d'un terroriste c'est
pas mais c'est V raison excusemiou la
mor
criminel criminel c'est pas pas en
prison si ce n'est pas de la légitime
défense il faut savoir que non c'est
pour ça que j'ai répondu oui cy si c'est
de la légitime défense ok mais
rien'est-ce que tu
racpe c'est
lé la
déf attend qu'onre à partir du moment où
tu attaques avec des avec des armes une
armur tu sais un pe à ah non par
ailleurs par ailleurs tu sais bien que
la légitime défense c'est une réponse
proportionnée ils étaient armés donc lui
est sort une arme par par parce qu'il
est paniqué et dans la panique il
riposte parce qu'il a parce qu'il a peur
pour sa vie ça va être tout l'objet de
ce procès où on va évidment on va
laisser finir parce que je sais pas je
veux dire que Cyril rien ne prouve qu'il
s'agit de légitime défense défendre un
bien si vous défendez une armurerie
d'accord contre des agresseurs ça ne
justifie pas de tirer
pour le moment nous en sommes là regarde
derre regarde ce qu' a derrière Cyr la
légitime défense c'est réponse immédiate
c'est c'est pendant le temps de
l'agression ça a eu lieu pendant le
temps de l'agression c'est une menace
réelle oui il s'est senti réellement
menacé par saz laiss parler les Ch s'il
te plaît quand tu vois des braqueurs tu
es pas
menacé quand tu vois des braqueurs il
pas menacé il va leur faire des crêpes
il ét TR non mais lui c'est exactement
ça AR il v arriver chez lui il arver
chez les mecs qui veut monsieur ils
étaient TR trois et ils étaient armés il
était seul enfin proportionnel à la
gravité proportionnel ils étaient les
trois armés il était il a rosté parce
qu'il il a cru que
luiême pourquoi tu sais tout mieux que
les autres ben moi je ne sais
rien donc je ne sais pas si c'est de la
légitime défense ou non si ce n'est pas
de la légitime défense c'est hicide
involon je dis pas des btis il est quand
même en garde vue c'est pas moiux qu' a
en prison
il est en garde à vue pour que on sache
les circonstances du
Dr dans ton monde tu aurais fait quoi g
c'est arrêtez il y a Fatou qui dort tu
es dans une tu fais ton boulot dans une
armurerie tu as trois mecs qui
débarquent cagoulé et armé tu fais quoi
concrèement les gar arrêtez il y a fou
qui est en train de dormir vous allez la
réveiller non mais j'aimerais bien parce
que les sats tu les invites chez toi tu
arrêtez de dire des conneries arrêtez de
dire arrêtez de dire n'importe quoi
j'invite pas les squat che
Mo
[Musique]
je vous
expque prve qu' est lé- que tu racontes
arrête un peu non mais c'est tout le
truc Ren prouve
ça t Rais c'est tu es extrêmement genti
Clément et tolérant avec les les gens
qui le mal avec
les et tu s pi a les innoc
COMOC qui s levé le
matinend je pas inoc légaliste là il est
légaliste pas légaliste c'est pas
cohérent ton raisonnement alors si tu es
légaliste commence par dire je suis
content que le le content c'est ça le
drame vous êtes content
person par condamner le
braage
àam l'armu il aurait d faire un petit
break d'abord en disant au braqueur
attendez c'est quoi vos intentions
attendez 2 secondes attendez je tirer
mais dans vos pieds ça risque rien les
pieds ok c'est OK et en fait c'est ça
fait tu la vi non si vous la lo non non
maise il y a quelqu'un qui il y a
quelqu'un qui
réagitagit mais il a vraiment un cerveau
à l'envers un individu vient braquer ton
magasin donc du coup tu reposes c'est
logique mais il est vraiment chelou ce
type la
lo il y a quand même deux circonstances
aggravantes la première c'est que
d'abord ils sont trois ils sont ils sont
très armés on peut évidemment imaginer
qu'ils puisse prendre d'autres armes et
ensuite ils attaquent une armurerie donc
je veux dire à partir du moment où tu
attaques une armurie tu te doutes que
les tenanciers ça éventuellement servir
d'une arme donc il y a un risque
pours propos non plus en gros ce qu' dit
c'est
queterel de ça il faut aussi un petit
peu que la peur change de camp
bienitpère les condamn à la
PERP ichas peut-être pas t une solution
ou l'autre en fait peut-être mais tu
n'en sais rien c'est pu que tu étais pas
dans le magasin
peut pasis pas du côté
des chemise as vu ta gueule
regarde tu t'énerves c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça tu dis absolument n'importe quoi
moi je suis pas du côté des braur
est attends ça peut très mal se passer
il a un
réfleoc voil il aurait probblement
préféré ne pas le
tuer es toujours du côté du Laxis on
peut rien faire c'est la lo c'est le
seul pays en France où on va
débat grand pays quelqu'un qui se fait
braquer il tue il y a même pas de
débat
m
Raon on est le seul pays qui qu'est-ce
qu'il a lui à dire
des comment comment tu peux avoir de la
peine et de la pitié pour les braqueurs
ce sont des gens don le métier si on
peut appeler ça un métier consiste à
s'armer à terroriser les gens et à
gagner de l'argent de manière
extrêmement
mal tu es braqueur tu te fais tuer tant
pis pour toi voil pour que ce soit
acceptable l'armurier aurait dû faire
quoi voilà il y a les tris braurs qui
arriv avec avec des
armes pas quoi répondre c'est
çameéo ré mais il ne peut pas répondre a
pas de réponse il va regarder sur le
truc sur le Code civil alors est-ce que
j'ai le droit de tirer à quel endroit
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il fait
concrètement tu reproche à jacqu de pas
avoir d'arguments alors explique-nous ce
qu'il aurait dû faire pour ne pas aller
en prison réponds ou pas oui bah oui
j'aimerais bien parce que tu sauras pas
il faut que la réponse soit
proportionné on ne sait mais on ne sait
pas quelle était la menace exacte il a
été menacé c'est pas un argument quo
c'est pas un
argument est-ce que vous voulez me tuer
ou
pasil était directement menacé c'est la
légitime défense si a pour dans les
ampoules sont ven pour tirer
pouroi c'est pas moi qui fait la loi C
c'est la loi je vous répque
Laer prison moment donné il a une
affaire de morale quand tu es magistrat
mais oui quand tu es magistrat et que tu
rends la justice il y a un moment donné
où tu dois donner exemple société toi
ton exemple pour la société c'est les
braqueurs c'est pas de leur faute et le
type faut qu'il aille en prison mais
enfin c'est scandaleux c'est évidemment
le contraire Fran surtout sauvé des vies
parce qu'il ven piquer des armes on sait
pas qu'il aurent fait av d' CELI
qui recherch dans l'enquête sur la mort
d'un lui se POS la question c'était la
légitime défenseou pas le gars avait
déjà tué un mec un AD dans Val de mais
question
vousêesjà leerette question avant de
savoir si répon
proportionn mag
grotesque SC mais c'est bien be les lois
les théories
et des tableau en disant la réponse
proportionnée le mec il a une demisee
pour réagir mets-toi à sa place ensuite
c'est quoi une réponse proportionnée
c'est quoi tuas tro mecs armés qui qui
arrive chez toi dans ton magasin c'est
quoi tu les tus une
derè quelle est la réponse proportionnée
alors toi elle dépend mais tu es bouché
ou
me de la situation tu comprends ce que
ça veut dire directement
TI et voilà mais quand tu es paniqué
comment tu fais en fait pour faire une
réunion avec
tome tout l'ce que tu aurais fait to
sûement j'ai pas utilisé une arme
j'aurais pas pr ta voix c'est une
arme
coup ça suffit
maintenant non mais qu's auraient
peut-être peur les
mecs ah tu m'as attaqué tout à
l'heure
mais il y a plein de gens qui veulent
savoir qu'est-ce que tu aurais fait mais
il le dira pas partir espérer que ma tu
vas pas t'y mettre
aussi pas eu ton avis à part partir moi
j'étais pas pour te défoncer à la base
pu que tu cherch pu que tu cherches à
part partir à part tu vois trois
braqueurs et tu leur dis allez-y monieur
prenez tout à part partir si tu as peur
et que tu es dans une armurie ils
rentrent dans une armurerie les mecs ils
vont braquer déjà faut être débile pour
aller braquer une armuie il rentent
braquer une armurie TR avec un qui a
déjà un passé qui a participé à la mort
d'un ado le gars lui tire dessus moi
j'espère que le gars là il est
l'armurier j'espère qu'il ira pas en
prison même pas une journée parce qu'on
a eu un témoignage là tout à l'heure qui
nous explique qu'il y a quelqu'un qui a
brûlé une femme qui va sortir en 2030 tu
parlais de perpétuité le gars il a brûlé
une femme il va sortir en 2030 on nous
explique qu'il y a des 3 heures de
visite dans un salon on nous explique
que guorge est sympathique bah j'espère
qu'il ira jamais en prison lui parce que
les mecs qui doivent aller en prison
c'est les mecs qui l'ont braqué faut pas
inverser les choses c'est pas le
braqueur c'est pas le l'armurier qui
Parr a témoignag comm on vientendre30
est de arrête de croire la perpété et
lui ils sont rentrés dans son armuriie
ils ont voulu le braquer ils ont fait
les malins il y en a un qui est mort
malheureusement P son âme mais c'est
fini rideau il a joué il a perdu terminé
j'espère qu'il aa pas en prison voilà
c'est tout pas
pasend pas prendre tte mais on cherche à
comprendre des choses de perpétuité si
lui lui aujourd'hui il va en prison au
moins il va ressortir vivant dans 2 ans
de la prison l'armurier sinon il était
mort alors a quelqu'un il y a quelqu'un
qui est d'accord avec vous euh ouais
quelqu'un qui travaille je suis
totalement d'accord avec Gill braqueer
n'a pas forcément l'intention de tuer on
nôte pas la vie de quelqu'un sous
prétexte qu'il vient voler non mais
alors ça ça je suis pas d'accord pas
d'accord ou je suis pas d'accord du tout
donc attends attendsends doncar tu veux
dire non les gars vous inquiétees pas je
viens juste voler hein vous emmerdez pas
non
mais des la cagoule c'est pour rigoler
les gars on vient juste voler vous
emmerdez pas tirez pas mais arrête un
peu arrête un peu arrête un peu avec ta
loi arrête un
peu déf des biens ne justifie pas un
homicide person il y a TR braqueurs qui
rentrent chez elle lui et toute sa
famille qui pr les CL de sa voiture qui
la télé n'importe quoi il va dire merci
beaucoup merci d'être passé ce soir
c'est gentil alors je sais pas qui c'est
mais alors lui c'est le dernier des
abrutisvoyex non toi tu es légaliste tu
es légaliste je pe Mo je pas ça moi
je je l'aime
beaucoupaime beaucoup non mais mais
parce que vous prenez le problème à
l'envers à chaque fois les mecs rentrent
pour braquer les mec tuas braqué
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'on te fasse une
ha d'honneur parce que tu es parti avec
des pour all
tuer qu PARP unurre qui rentre dans une
c'est pour aller chercher qui des pommes
des armes qu'estce qu'il va faire avec
les armes aprs qu'estce qu' va commettre
avec les armes derrière alors ah il a le
droit alors alors il mon AM il y a mon
ami G qui te répond s dit mon frérot qui
me dit pardon mais depuis quand la
justice est-elle juste en France qu'il a
perdu il eu des problèmes mais il t'aime
pas Tim pas il t'aime pas non mais non
mais alors non parce que pour résumer
après on on va cl le débatus Gill Verdez
en fait dit les gars sont venus ils
étaient armés cagoul mais peut-être qu'
avaient juste l'intention de voler et
que la réponse est disproportionnée puis
que le mec en a tué Gil Verdes le roi
des conneries excusez-moi he moi je peux
pas supporter d'entendre ça excuse-moi g
je t'aime beaucoup je serais très sympa
en 2024 avec toi mais entendre des
conneries pareiles écoute-moi bien moi
ça me ah mais vraiment tu vas me
flinguer le
weekend Jean-Michel non mais tuentends
les conneries qui raconent comme je
disais tout àure il faire tirer dessus
pour dire au lieu de dire la loi est mal
faite au lieu dire la loi est mal faite
puisque dans tous les autres pays du
monde ça passe comm ça
jamais non mais arrêtez arrêtez les deux
les deux s'il vous
PLT les
magistrats oui loi ça s'interprète il y
a une question de morale comme l'a très
bien dit Raymon attends en plus tu
imagines ils auraient peut-être braqué
25 armes et commis d'autres fait
justeès moi je pense parce y a une loi
que c'est forcément bien je pense qu' un
problème de
légitime un problème la légitime défense
en France parce qu'il y a plein de gens
qui ont enfin il y a des gens qui ont
soit blessé soit tué des gens mais
c'était soit eux soit l'agresseur en
fait donc je pense que n'importe qui ici
re choisi sa propre vie c'est normal
bien sûr qu'est-ce
qu'il dire la loi et la loi non mais le
risque avec vos élucubrations
c'est le risque le risque
avecation peut pas dire que tu sois dans
le vrai on peut pas dire que tu es que
des succès avec les idées que tu se rque
c'est
queur dequer il faut AR c'est il pour il
dans comme au
ÉtatsUnis non tu dis absolument pour
dans o la
justice la loion c'est la plus grande
avancée de la justice avant tu prenais
une claque tu prenais une hachette tu
lui coupais la tête mais au contraire
maintenant l'arip proportionné c'était
des plus grandes
noou tuud dis un peu le droit tu verras
c'est c'est la base de la justice
c'estàdire que on vous attaque vous tuez
non
vousez prop et propornellement c'est
quandé par des armes la justice c'est
pas la vengeance he
d'accord c'est quoi c'est quoi
quoi r la juste peine la
proportionnalité la juste peine voilà
VUR l'armurier c'est pas une vengeance g
c'est pas une préméditation il se dit
pas oh là là si jamais un jour a
braqueur P pouir les
assassiner renarm il est venu travailler
lui tout il Ren r cont l'ARM tu restes
trop sur l'esprit de sur la loi et rien
la lo mais
oui c'est nul il y a il y a aussi un
devoir de donner un bon exemple à la
société voilà ce que tu sembles oublier
c'est aussi ça par avec ton cœur et
combien même s'ils étaient venus juste
pour voler même s'ils étaient venus
juste pour voler je trouve ça normal
c'est regrettable encore une fois mais
qui qui se fasse tirer dessus tu viens
avec une arme quel est le message envoyé
c'est que tu il y a un danger pour ta
vie sinon tu ne viens pas avec une arm
sinon qu' viennent à visage découvert y
a quelque chose qu'on pas dit c'est
qu'il a eu plusieurs coups de tiré hein
c'est
cà même le fait de brandir une arme je
suis désolé c'est une menace réelle enf
mais
oui il y a quelqu'un il a jolie qui nous
dit sur Twitter quelqu'un qui nous dit
sur Twitter couna la légitime défense en
France c'est le droit de bruster une
fois qu'on est mort voilà pour le verdz
je pense que c'est c'est pas mal résumé
de la part de jolie sur sur Twitter g
Verdez non non benah non c'est pas une
fois qu'on est mort c'est que ce soit
proportionnel c'est tout et là là vous
moi sa excuse-moi mais comment tu veux
mais non mais comment mais je te jure
mais Jean-Michel quand j'entends ça mais
je peux plus entendre des bêtises pareil
excuse-moi on est déjà le le le quoi on
est le 11 janvier je peux plus déjà je
peux plus excuse-moi je peux plus
Jean-Michel tu lui parles non mais c'est
ce qui est fou c'est que mais non non
mais comment donc donc il va se dire le
gars donc il y a des gars qui arrivent
trois gars qui arrivent quiagoulé avec
des armes ils viennent de il va attends
attends attends on va voir parce que in
on va quand même voir on va voir quand
même l'attitude des gars et après on va
voir si on reposte ou pas y j'ai une
question à vous poser cyil se coup de
tirer c'est pas il y a pas il y a pas
juste un coup Gill il y a SEP coups de
tirer le voisin qui à côté parle de
Rafale donc si tu veux on est quand même
ti mon pote s an Gill devrait aller
faire un tour en prison pour se rendre
compte de ce qui est réellement la
justice tiens bah tu devrais y aller bah
il va t'amener Sandy tiens tu vas voir
le moin toi V le malin bah non mais tu
voulais c'est quoi ta question ma
question c'est pourquoi alors vous exp
ça démarre mal pourquoi quoi pourquoi
l'armurier est-il aujourd'hui
actuellement en garde à vue pourquoi
parce qu' savoir
passà et ben exactement donc on va
savoir ce qui s'est passé comment ça ça
n'a rien à voir on place en prison c'est
je dis je te le dis d'office même si
quoi qu'il est fait sa place n'est pas
en prison est-ce qu'on peut lui
demanderon pe lui demander mme si on
établit que c'était pas du tout de la
légitim il y a des mecs qui viennent
braquer pour moi c'est sa place elle est
pas en prison c'est moi et voilà je te
dis c'est moi et c'est beaucoup de monde
on va voir ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs je pense encore une fois
ils sont encore d'accord avec voilà verd
toujours la spirale de l'échecr penser
son comp tu es le seul à avoir raison
qu mais en fait c'est ça c'est que tu as
raison faire une séquence les Français
sont des cons a toujours raison c'est
ça je pense plutôt que je suis con et
que les Français ont raison donc voilà
moi c'est ma minorité je suis honte
pouruc voilà c'est mon opinion est
minorire de opinion et
minorit no éubration on est 93% àens
donc pas les
question toutes les vacances il a plein
gens qui m'ont abordé pour parler t PP
et la question qui revenait le plus
souvent est
malureusement
US ça c'est ça je suis pas d'accord
c'est un génie heureusement qu'il est là
heusement les gens m' demand c'était
pas pas non plus un fon une
[Applaudissements]
verrordire heureusement qu'il est
là il est très fort il est très fort
désolé non non tu pas une pu franchement
il est excellent mais c'est vrai qu'il
nous rend fou c'est un truc de fou sans
déconner c'est un truc de fou tiens
nouvelle plan